order the eyes to the right 327 the nose  the left 299 the eyes to the right 327  the nose to the left  299 so the eyes of it the eyes have it  unlocked order yes  point of order mr. Hillary Ben thank you  very much indeed mr. speaker the house  has spoken to see if the other place  passes the bill then I say to the Prime  Minister that this house expects him to  uphold the law and to fulfill the  obligations that will be placed upon him  by this bill and prevent this country  from leaving the European Union on the  31st of October without a deal may I  also mr. speaker thank the clerks for  their assistance right honourable  gentleman furred Dorset West and others  for their great help  and they are also joined my right  honourable friend the member for hope  and and some pancreas in most warmly  applauding the bravery and the courage  of many on that side of who have stood  by their convictions in the national  interest  [Applause]